they're celebrating the early arrival of
the weekend at midnight in Samoa they
skipped an entire day meaning this year
Friday the 30th of December simply
didn't exist as you can see in the
background and you know there's a lot of
excitement going on here the change is
all for the whole country for the
business community as well as the
general public we now feel that we have
crossed the line and we now feel that we
are closer to our families and friends
on the other side in New Zealand
Australia so the excitement here tonight
located halfway between New Zealand and
Hawaii the South Pacific island was 20
miles east at the International Dateline
making it ten hours behind London but
its neighbors and main trading partners
Australia and New Zealand were almost a
day ahead of Samoa
so the island has now jumped to the west
side of the International Dateline
catching up with the time zones of
Sydney and Wellington making working
with them easier there are many
individual businessmen who have
indicated to me that the move is very
very beneficial for their business
anyone who's missed their birthday may
feel a bit aggrieved but most Samoans
seem happy with the change I think it's
beneficial for some more economically
politically socially it's good for
someone people that these overseas it's
good very good
and by skipping straight to New Year's
Eve Samoa will be among the first places
to welcome in 2012 Becky Johnson Sky
News